it was 1883 when computer programming
started after centuries hundreds of
programming languages have come into
existence in the quest to be the most
agile and powerful enough to dominate
the industry a few impeccable ones
managed to withstand the test of time
and a few seem a lot ahead of time now
the question arises which of these
programming languages are the ones you
should learn so you are already watching
simply learn and today we bring you the
list of the top 10 programming languages
to learn in the year 2023. at number 10
we have rust when the Achilles heel of C
plus plus was revealed many companies
including Dropbox Firefox cloudflare and
many others needed to find a solution to
code safety in 2020 Russ came into the
picture rust is a multi-paradigm general
purpose programming language develop by
Firefox as an operational replacement
for C plus plus but rust was more
capable than just offering memory and
code safety Russ's high performance
compiler makes it ideal for processing
heavy data loads currently meta Amazon
Microsoft and many organizations are
dependent on Rust for several operations
the salary of a rust programmer is nine
lakh rupees in India in the United
States of America the salary is around a
hundred and ten thousand dollars per
annum at nine we have go programming
language also known as golang Google
designed a simple yet statistically
typed programming language that is a
brilliant combination of advanced memory
safety and garbage collection with the
Simplicity of the C language golang was
originally developed to support the
programming for networking and
infrastructure requirements go seem to
be a viable substitute for high
performance programming languages like
Java currently golang has a wide range
of applications across cloud computing
server-side scripting devops and many
more companies like twitch Uber Dropbox
and Google have adopted the go language
the average salary of a go developer is
135 000 USD and in India the salary of a
go developer is 10 lakh Rupees annum
based on your experience next we have
kotlin many believe kotlin is the future
that surpasses Java peculiarly there's
more Java can do than just develop
Android kotlin just makes things easier
for Android when compared to Java both
these powerful programming languages are
put on head-to-head comparison in
Android
but kotlin is designed based on Java yes
kotlin runs on jvm more on the
differences in our kotlin versus Java
video in the I button above Ming and
many more companies are active users of
kotlin the salary of a kotlin developer
in India is 10 lakh Rupees per annum and
in America the salary is 140 000 per
annum at seven we have SQL structured
query language is one of the most
successful languages and is considered
an important skill for every programmer
lately SQL is a data language that is
used to create data tables it stores
data communicates with the database and
manipulates data to fetch the required
results which is a major part of data
analytics companies like NTT data
Microsoft Accenture and others use SQL
the salary of an SQL Developer in India
is one million one hundred thousand
rupees and one hundred thousand dollars
in the USA at six we have typescript
typescript is Microsoft's yet another
powerful programming language
typescripts share similarities with
JavaScript but follow strict and
tactical practices with brilliant
tooling at any scale
companies like Accenture Microsoft and
more use typescript the salary of
typescript developers in India is two
million two hundred thousand per annum
in America the salary is 160 thousand
dollars per annum at five we have Swift
if you want to develop anything for
Apple Swift is your savior originally
Apple used Objective C it was one of the
oldest programming languages that needed
programmers to be well aware of a large
variety of libraries Objective C was
verbose and time consuming to adapt so
Apple develops Swift and migrated from
Objective C dramatically minimizing the
efforts and time required to develop
software and applications for Apple
devices apart from Apple companies like
uber Robinhood and a few more financial
companies are active users of Swift
Apple software developers are highly
paid Professionals in India Swift
developers are paid 10 lakhs per year
and Swift developers bag about ninety
thousand dollars per annum in America up
ahead we have C and C plus plus the
humble languages of the entire clan of
programming C is titled the mother of
all programming languages the veteran
programming language has contributed a
lot to developing new languages
compilers databases and one of the most
popular operating systems Microsoft
Windows
on the other hand C plus plus is an
advanced version of C with
object-oriented programming abilities C
plus plus is used for web development
games and much more companies like
Microsoft Netflix and many more use
these programming languages the average
salary of C and C plus developers in
India is 10 lakhs per annum in the USA
the salary is one hundred and twenty
thousand dollars per annum next we have
the top three programming languages
you've been waiting for at three we have
JavaScript the most versatile and
Powerful language that turned the face
of the internet JavaScript is a leading
programming language with the highest
number of communities and active users
worldwide an astonishing number of 65
percent of programmers around the world
use JavaScript
sharing the podium are python with 48 in
the second and Java with 33 percent in
the third
JavaScript is used majorly for web
development by companies like Netflix
Google PayPal big basket and more
the salary of a JavaScript developer in
India is one million six hundred
thousand per annum and in the USA the
salary is one hundred and thirty five
thousand dollars per annum at number two
we have Java
Java is Invincible among all languages
Java has the largest community
repositories and support it has spread
its roots into every software framework
mobile application big data and
operating system you name it Java did it
I.T giants like Ming and many other it
firms use Java the salary of a Java
developer in India is one million two
hundred thousand per annum and in the
USA the salary is a hundred and twenty
thousand dollars per annum finally our
number one programming language is
python
many believe that python is one of the
newest programming languages as a matter
of fact it's a veteran programming
language that is a lot older than Java
python was developed keeping one thing
in mind Simplicity python is not verbose
and it comes with the most simplistic
syntax python shares similar credibility
as Java in terms of operations and has
established its firm foot in the field
of data science and data analysis lately
Ming and it giants like Intel Pixar IBM
and more use python python ears earn
handsome salaries the salary of a python
programmer in India is 1 million per
annum and in the USA the salary is a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars per
annum that concludes our list of top
programming languages for the year 2023
what are you waiting for get started
with your programming Journey with
simply learn where we offer courses for
all the languages discussed links in the
description let us know in the comments
section which one is your favorite
programming language and why hope you
enjoyed the video don't forget to like
this and share it with your friends and
subscribe to Simply learn to never miss
out on any updates thanks for watching
until next time stay safe and keep
learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here